I want to take up in Volume 12 from May the 10th, 1919, for as long as the divine will
lasts in the soul, so does the divine life last within her.
This is a very important statement.
I mean, here it again, as long as the divine will last, so does the divine life last in
the soul. Louisa Sitch was very afflicted and worried about her state, and Jesus came
and spoke to her.
My daughter, he said, "What are you doing?
The thought of yourself makes you go out of my will.
This is extremely important for us, that all our self-reflection pulls us out of the divine
will.
If we are locked into the divine will, then we are having his thought, and we're responding
to him, not to ourselves.
The thought of yourself makes you go out of my will.
And don't you know that for as long as my will lasts in you, so does the divine life
last within you.
And that as soon as my will ceases, so does the divine life cease, and you take back your
human life with all the problems that go with it."
That's a beautiful exchange that you make, he said.
The same happens with obedience for as long as the obedience lasts, so does the life of
the one who commanded last in the one who obeys.
But as soon as the obedience ceases, so does one take back one's own life.
And then he tells her about the future, and I want to give you Amos 3, 7, that the Lord
never does anything without telling his prophets first.
"Then as though sighing," he said, "you do not know the ruin that the world will fall
into, looking forward to World War II and World War III."
And everything that has happened until now can be called a game compared to the chastisements
that will come.
I do not let you see them all, so as not to oppress you too much.
And I, seeing the obstinacy of man, that is the problem.
The obstinacy is hardness, so that's Jeremiah 17, 7 to 9, or 10, that the human heart is
perverse, and it's full of evils.
When I see the obstinacy of man remaining as though, when I see the obstinacy of man,
he said, "I remain hidden inside of you," and he said, "You should be praying together
with me, and you shouldn't be thinking about yourself.
So I want to give you two Corinthians 10, 5, that every thought must be captured and given
to Christ."
So May the 16th, 1919, the effects of the acts done in the divine will, and the sun is
the image of those acts.
So Louisa was thinking, "How can it be that just one act done in the divine will multiplies
into so many as to do good to everybody?"
At that moment, she said, "My sweet Jesus moved in my interior, and with the light that
He sent me, He told me," because that light is infused knowledge.
My daughter, an image of this you can find in the sun, in the sky.
The sun is just one thing in the universe.
It's heat and it's light, it's all one thing.
And yet this sun multiplies in everyone, giving to each one its light and its heat according
to the various circumstances.
For man, it is the light of every eye, of every action, and of every step.
And if the creature varies the action or in any way the light follows her, though the
sun still remains just one entity having all these effects.
The sun multiplies in all nature, giving to each thing its different effects.
It's rising, it embellishes all nature, and its light multiplying in the night frost forms
the dew, spreading upon all plants, a silvery mantle, which gives such prominence and beauty
to all nature as to astonish and enchant the human gaze.
So much so, that man with all his industriousness is incapable of forming one single drop of dew.
This is God's miracle of nature.
Go further on, he said.
Go to the flowers.
The sun gives color and fragrance to them, and not one color only, but to each one its
own distinct color and fragrance.
Then go to the fruits.
Instead, with its light and heat it gives sweetness and maturation to the fruits.
It gives diversity of sweetness to each fruit, though the sun is still only one thing.
It fertilizes and makes other plants grow, so all nature receives life from the sun,
and each thing has its own distinct effect that befits it.
So now let's come to the act and the divine will, because that's all an image of them.
Now if the sun does this because it is up high 93 million miles above us, it's up high,
and therefore it can affect everything which is down below.
Now we need to remember that because living in the divine will is living up high with God,
and so you can affect everything that is down below at a much lower level.
Now if the sun does this because it is up high and makes itself the life of all creation,
which lives down below, though the sun is just one thing, much more so are the act done
in my will, as the soul rises in me to fuse in the divine will and operates in the height
of my will that is in the summit of perfection.
And more than the sun, these act place themselves as the guards of all creatures, the guards
are the protectors of all souls in order to give them life.
Although it's only one act in the divine will, like the sun it darts over all souls
and some it embellishes, some it fertilizes with grace, some it melts the cold inside
of them, for some it softens the heart, for some it dispels the darkness in them, and
for some it purifies and burns, giving to each one the different effects that are needed
according to the greater or lesser dispositions of each one.
So here we have an absolutely extraordinary description of the variety of effects that
comes from act done in the divine will.
And this happens also in the sun that shines over your horizon.
If the ground is sterile, the sun gives little development to plants.
If the seed of the flower isn't there, the sun with all its light and heat doesn't make
it sprout.
If man does not want to activate himself in operating, the sun makes him earn nothing.
So if human beings are not prepared to cultivate the fields, well the sun can't help.
So the sun produces goods in the creation according to the fecundity of the grounds and also the
attitude or the response of mankind.
In the same way these act done in my will, though they run for the good of all, they act according
to the dispositions of each soul and according to the attitude of the soul who lives in the
divine volition.
So each additional act done in my will is one more sun that shines over all souls.
Now in these times of distress with the COVID-19 virus threatening everyone, it is so wonderful
to know that our act in the divine will shine over all souls, giving them whatever it is
that they actually need.
So we just need to multiply the act done in the divine will.
So this is Louise's response.
Afterwards she said, "I tried to fuse myself in my Jesus and in his will, multiplying my
thoughts in his in order to repair and substitute for all creation's intelligences past, present
and future.
And from the heart I said to my Jesus, how I wish to give you with my mind all the glory,
the honor, the reparation for the whole human family, even for the lost souls, who have not
given to you anything with their intelligence.
And he as though pleased kissed me on my forehead, saying to me, and I with my kiss seal all
the thoughts, your thoughts with mine, that I may always find in you all created minds
and in their name, receive continuous glory, honor and reparation."
May the 22nd 1919, in the era of the living of the divine will, souls will complete the
glory on the part of creation.
This is the very good news of May 1919.
You in my usual state, my little mind was wandering in the holy will of God, and I don't
know how.
I understood how the creature does not render to God the glory which she's obliged to give,
and so Louise said she felt embittered by this.
And my sweet Jesus wanting to instruct and console me through an intellectual light he
told me lest he infuse knowledge again, he's teaching her directly in her inner most being.
My daughter, he said, "All of my works are complete, all of God's works are complete,
all of Jesus's works in his incarnation are complete.
So the glory of the creature must give me, sorry, so the glory that the creature must
give me has to be complete also.
And the last day of planet earth will not come if the whole of creation does not give
me the honor and the glory wanted and established by me."
Now, there you have a very important piece of information where everybody's talking
about the end times.
We are in the end of an old era and we're at the beginning of the new era.
And so we're going through very great turbulence at the moment and purification as well.
But the last day of the human race will not actually come until God has achieved what
he set out to get from the human race that I find comforting.
And what some do not give me, he said, "I will take from others."
In these souls, I double the graces which the others reject from me.
And from these souls, I receive double love and glory.
Now, these souls who are giving him everything, of course, are souls in the divine will.
To others, according to their dispositions, I reach the point of giving graces that I
would give to ten, I want to give you their Matthew 25, verse 29.
To others, I will give those that I would have given to a hundred and to others again
those that I would have given to a thousand.
And sometimes I will give graces which I would give to cities, to provinces, and even to
entire kingdoms.
So there are going to be very great saints in the divine will.
And these love me, these souls love me, and they give me glory for ten, for a hundred,
for a thousand, for cities, for provinces, and so on and so forth.
In this way, my glory is completed on the part of creation.
And when I see that the creature cannot reach in spite of her good will, I draw her into
my will.
And there she finds the power to multiply one single act as much as she wants.
That's why my favorite thing to say to the Lord is I want to multiply this act to infinity
for an infinitude of time so we reach the absolute mactimum.
And she gives me glory, honor, and love which others do not give me.
This is why Jesus said, "I am preparing an era of the living in my will, the new and
divine holiness.
So that, for what they have not done in the past generations and will not do in this era
of my will, they will complete the love, the glory, the honor of the whole of creation."
And I will give them astounding and unheard of graces.
And this is why I call you to live in my will, and I whisper in your ear, "Jesus, I
lay at your feet the adoration, the subjection of the whole human family."
So let's join Blessed Mother and Louisa and all in the divine will as we pray this right
now, "Jesus, with your will fused in your holy will, I lay at your feet the adoration,
the subjection of the whole human family.
I place in your heart the I love you of all.
I place upon your lips, I impress my kiss in order to seal the kiss of all generations.
With my arms, I clasp you to clasp you with the arms of all, to bring you the glory of
all the works of creatures.
And I feel in you the adoration, the I love you, the kiss, et cetera, of the whole human
family, Jesus said.
How could I not give you the love, the kisses, the graces that I would have given to others?"
Now, he said, "Know my daughter that what the soul does on earth is the capital that
she makes for heaven.
Please put a VIP on that statement.
Let me read it for you again.
Know my daughter that what the soul does on earth is the capital that she makes for heaven.
For that I want to give you one Corinthians 3, verses 11 to 15, where Saint Paul tells
us that while we're on earth, we can make a tent for heaven, or we can make a house,
or we can make a palace, or we can make a kingdom.
Depends on us.
We can build with wood and grass, which won't survive.
We can build with stones, or we can build with gold and silver and precious jewels.
It's up to us.
Know if she has done little, she will receive little, that's 2 Corinthians 9, 6.
You reap what you sow.
If she has done much, she will receive much.
If one has loved me and glorified me for 10, she will receive 10 more contentment corresponding
to as much glory as will be loved by me, and will be loved by me 10 times more.
There I want to give you the parable of the talents in Matthew and Luke.
Matthew 25, 14 to 30, and Luke 19, verses, I couldn't tell you what it is, something
to verse 27, maybe 1 to 27, and Luke speaks of 10 pounds and 10 cities, this is the language
that Jesus is using here.
And so if we love him for 10, or 10 cities, that's the glory you got at heaven.
If another soul has loved me and glorified me for a hundred or for a thousand, she will
have the contentment, love, and glory for a hundred or a thousand.
In this way, I will give to creation what I've decided to give, and creation will give
me what I must receive from them, and my glory will be completed in everything.
So May the 24th, 1919, the soul in whom Jesus dwells, feels what the world sends to him.
And this is a very great insight that Jesus gives to us here as to why sometimes we feel
empty or cold or unable to pray or whatever it is that he's allowing us to feel what
is the condition that's going on in souls and the world.
I was feeling very oppressed and afflicted because of the privation of my sweet Jesus.
And I was saying to him with all my heart, come my life, without you I feel myself dying
and not so as to die, but only to always die.
"Come, I can take no more," she said.
And so Jesus came and he came to console her.
He said, "My daughter, I felt an irresistible need to pour myself out in love so he embraced
and he kissed her."
And Louisa said, "Jesus, how much you make me suffer.
The privation of you kills me.
All other pains would be nothing for me, or rather smiles and kisses of yours, but your
privation is death and pity.
Ah, Jesus, Jesus, you have changed."
So for that I want to give you SAM 63.
My soul is thirsting for you, my God.
Even my body is like a dry, weary land without water.
This desperate cry for God.
And also SAM 42, "I've nothing but tears for my bread, night and day, as they say to be
all day long, where is your God?"
Jesus interrupted Louisa and said, "Dorfer of my love.
You do not want to persuade yourself that I look at the world through you.
In other words, haven't I told you often enough what's going on?
You are my throne.
I am operating in the world in you and through you, and I look at the world through you.
And of course, if I am there and you and I are inseparable in the divine will, of course
you feel what's coming back to me.
Don't you want to persuade yourself that I look at the world through you?
And since I dwell in you, you are forced to feel what the world sends me, which is hardness,
darkness, sins, the fury of justice, coldness, etc.
So instead of thinking of my privation, you must think of defending me from the evils
that creature send me.
So here's a completely different way of looking at the whole privation that she's experiencing.
So whatever it is she's feeling that she's saying to her that you must make reparation
for that because that is what's coming against me in the world, you must think of defending
me from the evils that creature send me and of breaking the fury of my justice.
In this way, I will remain sheltered within you and the creatures will be struck less.
In other words, this is a higher way of being a victim soul because Louisa has so often complained
that she doesn't have the external sufferings anymore and he's trying to tell her you do
have them you're just not recognizing the way that the suffering is coming to you.
So June the 4th, 1919.
In order for redemption to be complete, Jesus had to suffer injustice, hatred and mockery.
So Louisa said she was thinking about the passion and especially about how Jesus found
himself under the storm of the scourges and she said, "When did Jesus suffer more in
the pains which the divinity had made him suffer during the whole course of his life
or on the last day on the part of the Jews?"
And then Jesus gives her infused knowledge and understanding which is terribly important.
So what Jesus is going to say to her is that the human beings no matter who they were could
only give him human sufferings and finite sufferings, but the divine love could give
him infinite sufferings.
So Jesus had infinite divine sufferings for the whole of his life and he had the finite
sufferings from the Jewish people on the final day.
So to me that is the drop of water in the wine of his redemption that we participate
in everything and you will remember that if you go back to the book of Exodus and the
people crying out to Moses for water that the Lord told him to go to a particular rock
and strike the rock and he said, "I will be there before you at that rock," which means
that Moses had to strike the Lord to receive this water.
Now that's a profound prophetic preparation for the fact that the Jewish people, the chosen
people, the ones who were chosen to cooperate with God in setting up the kingdom of God
on earth, that they had to strike the Lord in order that the living waters of redemption
would come from him.
And so it's a very extraordinary moment when a soldier opens the heart of Jesus and outflows
the blood and water representing the lifeblood of redemption.
So Jesus said, "My daughter, the pains which the divinity gave me surpassed by far those
which creatures gave me, it surpassed it both in power and in intensity.
It surpassed it in multiplicity and in length of time.
In other words, there's no comparison.
However, there was no injustice or hatred in anything, of course, that came from the
divinity because God is love.
And so the interior passion came from the highest love, which is God himself, one John
four seven and Sam one four five verse seventeen, God only ever acts out of love.
However, he said, "There was no injustice or hatred, there was only the highest love
and accord that is unity on the part of the three divine persons in the commitment which
I had to take upon myself to save souls at the cost of suffering and many deaths for
as many creatures as would come out into the light of creation, which the father had granted
me with highest love."
Now in Jesus' priestly prayer, in John 17 verse nine, he says, "Father, you gave them
to me, now I have redeemed them and I offer them back to you."
So the gift of the father to the son, the son, gifts back to the father after he has
redeemed us.
So neither injustice nor hatred exists in the divinity nor could they exist because there
would be a contradiction of God's person.
Therefore, the trinity was incapable of making me suffer the particular pains that the human
beings could make me suffer.
But man with sin had committed the highest injustice and hatred, et cetera, in other
words, all the deadly sins, and I in order to glorify the father completely in love,
I was to suffer injustice, hatred, and mockery, in other words, this could only come from human
beings and from the rottenness that was in their souls.
This is why on the last of my immortal days, I suffered the passion on the part of creatures
in which injustice, hatred, and mockery, revenge and humiliation was poured into him.
And Jesus says that these injustices and hatred and mockery and revenge and humiliation were
so many as to render my poor humanity the appropriate of all.
I want to give you Romans 5, 5, Jesus was made into sin for us.
And I want to give you Isaiah 52, 14, because Jesus said to the point where I no longer looked
like a man.
And that's exactly what Isaiah said.
They disfigured me so much that they themselves were horrified in looking at me because Jesus
in the torture that was given to him became the perfect image of what sin looks like in
our souls, that we become completely horrific to the eyes of God.
That's Habakkuk 1, 13, that the Lord is far too holy to look upon sin.
So in our interior, we become completely disfigured.
And we know that if you've met people who have really let themselves become very evil,
that you can see that evil also on their faces and in their eyes and in their bodies in the
end.
They disfigured me so much that they themselves were horrified looking at me.
I was the abject and the rejection of everyone.
So I could call them two distinct passions.
Naturally, one is divine, coming from love and the other is human, coming from sin.
The creatures could not give me as many debts for as many pains, for as many creatures and
sins that would be committed by them.
They were incapable of it because they're finite.
Therefore, the divinity took on this commitment, but with the highest love and accord on both
sides.
Now, that is the thing you really must understand, that the father and the Holy Spirit would
never have allowed this to happen to the son if he hadn't agreed.
And there's an insight into Genesis 22 when you have Abraham offering his son Isaac to
God, the scholars, Jewish and Christian scholars are both in accord in understanding that Abraham
could not have done this to his son.
His son is supposed to have been about 13 years of age when it happened.
So he could not have done it without his son actually agreeing to the sacrifice.
And therefore, the sacrifice of Isaac becomes a very powerful prophetic image of Jesus offering
himself in sacrifice to the father for God's will to be done on the earth, because that's
what Abraham wanted, that at any cost to himself, that God's will would be done for
all the future generations.
So Isaac agreed to that as well.
And here, Jesus says that the father and the Holy Spirit agreed with the son for this.
On the other hand, the divinity was incapable of injustice, et cetera.
And so creatures took over this area.
And he said, I completed the work of redemption in everything, how much souls cost me.
And this is why I love them so much.
Another day, Louisa was thinking, my beloved Jesus has told me so much.
And I, have I been attentive to do what he has taught me?
That's the issue, you see, will we actually do it?
It's one thing to study her writings, it's quite another matter to live the divine will.
Oh, how I lack in contenting him, she said, how incapable I feel in everything.
So his many teachings could even be my condemnation.
It's a misunderstanding on her part, so Jesus immediately responded.
He said, why do you afflict yourself, my daughter?
The teachings of your Jesus will never serve you as condemnation.
Even if you only did them once, it's always a star that you have placed in the heaven of
your soul, just think about that.
Even to do one act in the divine will is a star that you place in your soul.
When you do many acts in the divine will, you create heavens in your soul.
In fact, just as I extended a heaven over the human nature and my fiat studded it with stars,
so have I extended a heaven in the depths of your soul and you can fill it with suns
and stars as well.
It's entirely up to yourself.
And the fiat of the good that she does, because every good is the fruit of my will, this fiat,
this yes to doing the acts in the divine will, comes to embellish this heaven with stars.
So our commitment to the Lord, our fiat, our 100% being locked into his will and doing
the all the acts that come out of that creates whole heavens of suns and stars and galaxies
inside of us.
It's difficult for us to imagine that.
If she does a thousand good acts, then there's a thousand stars.
If she does a million of them, there's a million stars.
So think rather of repeating my teachings as much as you can in order to stood with stars,
the heaven of your soul, so that the heaven of your soul may not be inferior to the heaven
that shines above your.
So I want to give you Jeremiah 31, 31 to 34.
So when you do this, he said, each star will carry the mark of the teaching of your Jesus.
In other words, we do these acts because he has taught us and how much honor you will
give to me.
So June the 16th, 1919, there's no sanctity without the cross.
There's no shortcut.
We have to take the journey.
So Louisa was thinking, where are the pains that my sweet Jesus told me he would let me
take part in?
You see, she completely dismisses the privation which is driving her to the point of being
unable to cope, and she just doesn't look at it.
"I don't really said how you deceive yourself.
You calculate corporal pains."
You see, that's what we dealt with in volumes one to five.
That Jesus was giving Louisa corporal pains.
He was allowing her to experience actual nails and scourging and carrying of the cross or
whatever or a full crucifixion, and she was happy, "I'm participating."
It's corporal, but she's not appreciating the interior passion that he's allowing her
to experience now.
It's the same with us.
We give more attention to the body than to the soul.
He said, "I calculate the corporal and moral pains," which, of course, is the privation
for her.
Every time you've been without me, it was the deaths that you felt, and I felt myself
repaired for the many deaths that creatures give themselves with sin, that's mortal sin.
And you took part in the many deaths that I suffered.
This is the spiritual participation in the interior passion that Louisa is not really
appreciating.
When you felt cold, it was another little death that you felt, and you came to take part
in the coldness of other creatures who would want to cool down in my love.
But my love triumphing in their coldness absorbs it into me to feel the death of their coldness,
and I give them more ardent love.
So there's Louisa feeling the coldness that are in other souls, offering it to the Lord.
The Lord absorbs it into himself in the divine will, and he gives those souls the warmth
of his love that they need in order to grow spiritually.
It's the same with all your other pains, you said.
They were the evil's opposed opposite to those of creatures, which, like many little
deaths, made you take part in my deaths.
And then, don't you know that my justice when it is forced by the wickedness of people to
pour new scourges?
It suspends your pains, so when she gets a little bit of break from the torture she's
in, then she has the torture of not having the torture, which is extraordinary.
The evil, she said, will be so grave, this is 1919, so he's looking forward to World
War II and III.
They will be so grave as to be horrifying.
I mean, when we look back at World War II, we can't believe what they did.
It was just mind-bending.
I know that this is a pain for you, he said, but I too had this pain.
I would have wanted to free creatures from all pains, both in time and in eternity.
But this was not granted to me by the wisdom of the Father.
This is the perfect justice of God in operation, and I had to resign myself, he said, would
you perhaps want to surpass me and surpass my very humanity?
Add offer, he said, no kind of sanctity is without the cross.
You see, the cross for us is whatever it is that you find completely impossible, and
you'd give it to anybody, any time, under any conditions.
Many people confuse the cross, and they think that some little pain they have or some little
difficulty, it's not that.
The privation that Louisa is experiencing of Jesus' presence is the cross for her.
It's the thing she absolutely finds impossible to deal with.
That's the cross.
But he said there's no sanctity without a cross.
There's no virtue acquired without the union of pain.
So we have to remember that, and so the struggles we go through are okay, so long as we're really
letting the Lord have his victory in us.
No however, that I will repay you with interest for all my privations and for the very pains
that you would have wanted to suffer and cannot suffer.
Now that's very important as well.
Any threes of this you is great on this point.
She was locked up in a monastery and couldn't leave it under solemn vows.
And yet she said to the Lord, "I would want to be a missionary taking your gospel to the
ends of the earth.
I would want to be a priest celebrating your Eucharist and so on and so forth."
And the Lord said, "Don, the fact that she was still in her monastery doing her tiny little
things every day made no difference whatsoever.
If you wanted it, he would do it for you."
And so she became the secondary patroness of France.
So June the 27th, 1919, "The heart of Jesus is the spring of glory and grace."
Jesus said, "My daughter, for as many virtues as my heart, we say, my sacred heart, practiced,
so many springs were formed and a spring is a source of water.
Water is the symbol of grace, is the symbol of redemption, is the symbol of eternal life.
So I want to give you Isaiah 55 verses 1 to 3.
I want to give you Isaiah 12 verses 1 to 8."
And as these springs formed, he said, "So did innumerable rivulets gush forth with spurting
up into heaven, wordily glorified the Father in the name of all.
And these rivulets from heaven fell down again for the good of creatures."
Okay?
Let's Ezekiel 47, "The water flowing from the right-hand side of the temple, which of
course is the right-hand side of Christ, and flowing out right out into the arabah.
The arabah is the desert-like place, transforming it into a fertile land."
So these waters of grace flow into the desert of our souls and fertilize us them, making
them fruitful spiritually.
Now as creatures also practice the virtues, little springs are formed in their hearts.
Now this is John 7 verses 37 to 39, where Jesus said, "Come and drink, and drink as much
as you want, and eventually out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water.
In other words, you become a source of life for other people."
So as creatures also practice the virtues, little springs are formed in their hearts,
from which their little rivulets gush forth, which cross with my rivulets, that's John
14, 12, my disciples will do the same works as I do when I go to the Father.
So as creatures also practice the virtues, little springs are formed in their hearts,
from which their little rivulets gush forth, which cross with my rivulets, and spurting
up together with mine glorify the celestial father and descend for the good of all, forming
such harmony between heaven and earth that even the angels remain amazed at the enchanting
sight.
Therefore be attentive to practice the virtues of my sacred heart.
So as to let me open the springs of my graces in you and through you.
So that's Galatians 5-22 and we'll take a break there.